[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
is porte le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines va ouvrir un
département sur ce secteur en plein
essor à la rentrée prochaine interview à
suivre dans quelques instants et que
bruce goldstein responsable
communication de la structure golf
l'open de france programmée début mai a
été officiellement reporté par
l'european tour les organisateurs n'ont
voulu prendre aucun risque par rapport à
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 plus
d'informations à suivre solidarité le
28e tiebreak est programmé ce 19 mai au
golf park
robert hersant ce rendez vous réunira
des stars autour d'une partie de golf et
d'enchères caritative nous aurons
l'organisatrice véronique chaplin avec
nous par visio actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer à ce titre nous
allons parler de volley ball dans le
championnat élite l'un des seuls qui
continuent à se disputer dans les
yvelines conflans andrésy jouy s'est
inclinée ce week-end sur le terrain
d'avignon à l'occasion de la 20e journée
les événements ont perdu 3 sets à 2 le
score 24 26 25 17 22 25 25 22 15 18
on écoute les réactions des joueurs du
nord du département est-ce que de la
fierté parce que on a tenu la dragée
haute aux deux
c'est la deuxième fois que
le pr
de fierté parce que l'état d'esprit il a
été au rendez vous
ça c'est faux
ça c'est plutôt un bon point dans
l'ensemble c'est mérité les changements
de joueurs
c'est la tendance
savoir avec c'est
satisfaire d'un point
les joueurs du nord du département
arrive tout de même à conserver la
troisième place du classement
un résultat golf également un nid
viennoise a brillé en afrique du sud
manon agi d'aliciens remporté ce
vendredi le cap town ladies open la
pensionnaire du golf de la boulie à
versailles s'est imposé à l'issue d'un
playoffs de deux trous contre la locale
qu'arago relayent à 27 ans et sa
première victoire en tant que
professionnel après cinq ans sur le
circuit
elle nous a envoyé cette vidéo depuis
l'afrique du sud bonjour à tous et manon
jbeli en direct de quelqu'un je viens de
remporter le calepin de ladies open
super contente car c'est ma première
victoire chez les professionnels depuis
mon passage qu en 2007
ce n'est à remercier mes sponsors des
constructions pro dérive inter parfums
kel away apparel et kel away we go vous
pouvez continuer à me susurre le seul
chat il est dur jusqu'à la fin du mois
de mai merci à tous et à bientôt
l'autre heavy noise alexandra bonetti
pensionnaires de saint germain en laye a
terminé à une prometteuse 25e place on
va maintenant parler is porte le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines veut ouvrir un
département de heath portes du sport
électronique à la rentrée prochaine pour
nous parler de cette volonté et nous
recevons sur ce plateau bruce goldstein
responsable marketing et communication
du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir je
rigole alors pourquoi vouloir installer
huit portes ouvrent le tour national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout
simplement alors prioritairement pour se
renouveler
on veut développer du sport et le couple
et à nos activités classiques qu'on a
depuis maintenant plus de sept ans ce
qui nous importe c'est de créer des
passerelles entre cet univers ea sports
mais également avec la santé et le sport
donc faire découvrir les sports oui
certes mais en tout en faisant découvrir
également la partie sportive qu'on a
qu'on a chez nous depuis depuis tant
d'années est ce que c'est un projet dans
les cartons depuis longtemps où
finalement c'est assez récent ça reste
quelque chose d'assez récent de par le
contexte actuel c'était important de
d'innover de réfléchir sur toutes ces
questions dont une fausse fort on
phosphore beaucoup sur sur ces
thématiques là le vélodrome est une
structure qui s'y prête totalement pour
le grand public je parle en matière
d'événements mais également en termes de
participatif
donc on aura des activités quotidiennes
autour du 10 sport en tout cas on y
réfléchit et on éventre réfléchit
également à toucher des organisateurs
extérieur pour l'organisation de ce type
de manifestation alors on sait que le x
porte c'est vraiment c'est en plein
essor en ce moment on en parle beaucoup
il ya des millions d'adeptes à travers à
travers le monde
est-ce que tout simplement ça permettra
au vélodrome d'avoir peut-être plus de
visibilité
peut-être aussi tout au vert c'est aussi
l'un des objectifs majeurs toujours de
démocratiser nos activités le ea sports
c'est une opportunité unique pour
toucher les génération y et z notamment
donc c'est aussi notre notre intime
conviction de pouvoir rassembler et
fédérer autour de ce type d'activité est
ce que vous avez pu peut-être discuter
que ces jeunes ou pas et j'avais un
territoire c'est des projets sur
lesquels on planche avec avec la
collecte avec la collectivité vous savez
que saint quentin en yvelines a été hué
plateforme d'expérimentation cng donc
c'est également le point de départ pour
réfléchir à ces thématiques et on
travaille tous main dans la main
également avec la fédération française
de cyclisme et notamment sur des
activations qu'on pourra mettre en place
pour les championnats du monde de 2022
cyclisme sur piste
alors le vélodrome nationale accueille à
des compétitions internationales mais
également locale le vélodrome ne fait
pas forcément toujours le plein est ce
que ça permettra peut-être aux vélos
donc de faire le plein ce type
d'événement d'être complémentaire en
tout cas on sait que leur handball par
exemple avait été avec enfin le
vélodrome avait cueilli du handball ya
quelques années avec le club d'issy
paris ça avait plutôt bien fonctionné
est ce que c'est une piste que vous
étudiez peut-être on sort sur toutes les
pistes
pourquoi pas accueillir intime aussi à
demeure dans le cadre de résidences mais
mais voilà pas qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup d'exemples vous l'avez cité
c'est évidemment des références pour
nous on veut surfer sur ses succès là et
encore une fois se diversifier notamment
à travers la brique ea sports sur
laquelle on planche activement encore et
encore alors le département à
fonctionner comment justement est-ce que
c'est plutôt pour les amateurs ou plutôt
pour les professionnels les deux vous
connaissez le front national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines voilà on
essaye de ratisser au plus large donc
avec la partie professionnelle mais
également amateur donc et orales y aura
la partie effectivement professeurs pour
la notoriété pour l'image mais c'était
aussi une activité qu'on va ouvrir au
grand public calqué sur le modèle
existant depuis maintenant sept 7 ou 8
ans et vous le disais peut-être des
teams c'est ça tout à fait preuve de
résidence
deux résidences sur différentes semaines
à thème les joueurs pourraient venir s'y
épanouir c'est encore une fois une
enceinte ultra moderne qui se prête
parfaitement à ce genre d'activité et le
public pourrait venir également
participer et assister aux affrontements
en one to one ou par équipe est-ce que
vous invitez déjà cetim à se présenter
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on en parle
nous en parle et qu'on en parle des
teams connu peut-être aussi aussi on
verra ça alors on parle de septembre
prochain
est-ce que tout sera prêt pour septembre
prochain où est ce qu'on peut imaginer
une arrivée du fils porte un peu plus
tardif peut-être je sais pas avec le coc
u19 qui qui est présent encore comme
vous le site locaux vides 19
malheureusement c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne maîtrise pas forcément on a peu
de visibilité c'est une ambition
d'ouvrir en septembre ça corresponde à
la nouvelle rentrée sportive du
vélodrome
donc oui c'est un critère qu'on a coché
c'est un vrai marqueur qui nous tient
très à coeur
maintenant évidemment s'interdit pas de
leur porte et si les justifications
venait à se présenter
cet homme c'est demain qu'est ce qui
vous reste à faire plus grand chose on a
beaucoup travaillé comme vous l'a dit on
a mis à profit cette période inédite
malheureusement pour le sport donc voilà
le modèle économique est sur le point
d'être finalisé on a encore une fois
beaucoup des changes avec saint quentin
en yvelines sur les thématiques de la
plate forme d'expérimentation 5g ça peut
être un vrai tremplin pour ce
département esport donc donc voix c'est
un projet est bien avancé qu'on arrêtait
encore une fois de concrétiser septembre
nous paraît réaliste
maintenant encore une fois sa demande
aussi des moyens financiers humains
forcément donc on est nous aussi en tant
qu'exploitant du vélodrome dans la tente
de savoir le dénouement de cette crise
sanitaire et pour déployer à l'issue
tous les efforts nécessaires
dans l'idéal le premier événement
d'ampleur pourrait intervenir quand on
travaille sur un événement international
de ea sports pour le mois de janvier
c'est à dire finalement c'est demain
donc plus en avant
airs et plus on se dit que ça reste un
timing très short donc pour s'assurer un
vrai succès alors on n'écarte pas la
possibilité de le reporter merci à vous
d'être passé sur ce plateau à bruce
goldstein le sport c'est donc pour
bientôt vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et on suivra
cela avec attention bruce on va reparler
golf la nouvelle est tombée en milieu de
semaine dernière l'open de france ne se
disputera pas du 6 au 9 mai au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
déjà annulé en 2020 la structure espère
pouvoir accueillir le rendez vous cette
année avec peut-être du public à montage
de lucas houdart
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour l'open de
france de golf déjà annulé en 2020 le
rendez-vous 2021 est officiellement
reportée
il ne se disputera pas à huit clos du 6
au 9 mai sur les greens saint quentinois
la décision fait suite aux nouvelles
annonces gouvernementales concernant la
propagation de kovy de 19 en france
envisagée cadres et on a beaucoup
travaillé de façon très proche avec
european tour avec la préfecture avec
les différents services et la décision
qui a été prise c'est la décision là là
là on va dire la safe au total cette
104e édition et attire entre 850 et 900
personnes venus de 25 pays différents
une difficulté dans le contexte
sanitaire actuelle pour les
organisateurs c'est compliqué avec
l'actuel mandat d'aider des notions de
850 personnes pour les faire manger
d'accord donc faire manger 850 personnes
en respectant les contraintes sanitaires
de deux mètres carrés par personne est
déjà ça c'est c'est un problème qu'il
faut résoudre le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines attend
désormais une nouvelle date dans le
calendrier du tour européen
le rendez vous pourrait être décalée à
la fin de l'été l'événement pourrait
cette fois-ci accueillir un peu de
public
un autre report dans les yvelines le
premier réalise 100 % électrique et 100%
féminin au monde ne partira pas début
mai de l'hôtel de ville de versailles
les organisateurs de l'équipe naturel
aventure ce ont décidé de reporter le
rendez vous dimanche 30 mai la décision
a été prise juste après les dernières
annonces du gouvernement par rapport à
elle
épidémie de kobe de 19 en france en
revanche pas de changement sur le
concept de l'événement les participantes
partiront des yvelines pour se rendre en
savoie avec une carte et une boussole le
défi sera évidemment de ne pas se perdre
enfin en tennis le tournoi de roland
garros a été officiellement reporté
d'une semaine par la fédération
française
le rendez vous se tiendra donc du 30 mai
au 13 juin avec des qualifications du 24
au 28 mai ce report devrait concerner 3
illinois la française chloé paquet
originaire de versailles
le saint germanois arthur rinderknecht
120e 900 29e joueur mondial et également
le jeune art
antoine ghibaudo 16 ans pour le tournoi
de roland garros juniors on va
maintenant a parlé d'un événement le 19
mai à prochain livre i noise véronique
chaplin va organiser un tournoi de golf
caritatif en réunissant des stars du
monde du sport le 28ème édition du tibre
aixois organisées au golf de hersant la
fondatrice et organisatrice véronique
chapat est avec nous via écran interposé
à bonsoir alors est-ce que vous allez
garder la formule habituelle du tiebreak
cette année alors nous nous conformons à
la formule habituelle qui est sur deux
parties la compétition amicale de golf
et une partie avec les enfants d
encadrement des olympiades avec des
champions qui viennent encadrer et donné
des conseils à nos enfants de la ccpo et
de trappes et puis il partit aussi dans
cher qu'avec un très convivial et là on
vient tous grades dehors avec le respect
des airs et niamey et du maître ou
aperta forme ludique on va leur pourrir
des pick a dream est ce que des enfants
des yvelines ont participé à l'événement
on sait que c'est un petit peu la
tradition tout à fait exactement donc on
avait un enfant de la rue ces lois dans
une fac loup vous n'allez donc pas du
lycée de trappes et puis c'était déjà
une belle mobilisation des yvelines
également en année les partenaires que
depuis un an
marien fait point cette gazelle et des
gens comme des concessions en vms la
dalle chesnais nos amis consoles etc qui
ont décidé de venir soutient
l'association et participer avec une
sportive de haut niveau
convivialité dans un evenemment de
partage et solidaire alors je le
rappelle c'est un tournoi de golf amical
on peut le dire est ce que c'est
vraiment amicale sur votre golf avec ses
stars n'ont alors on dit amical mais en
fait il ya un titre honorifique qui le
titre de champion des champions par
équipe de 4 et comme il ya roland-garros
comme m et que dans chaque équipe il ya
au moins deux hommes anciens
internationaux que ça soit des
professionnels de gaulle dont il est
champion d'autres sports ils se
bagarrent
il joue la gagne même dû à la bonne
humeur ce matin à l'âme au quotient nous
aurons des rugbymans comme famille
apollos fabien galthié qui ont confirmé
leur présence et beaucoup de gloire ont
cet esprit de 2,2 de gagner de 2,2 alors
qu'entre présente beaucoup autour de ça
même s'ils viennent pour les enfants je
peux vous dire que le titre il est super
complet et d'en bas
quand vous faites pour les convaincre
justement ces sportifs de haut niveau de
venir faire cette partie de golf
mais hier c'était particulièrement
difficile lors déjà faire les liens qui
nous qui nous lie depuis un quart de
siècle
on a des relations professionnelles et
amicales tout au long de l'année donc
c'est un effet de change de bons
procédés eux ils viennent dont la bonne
cause et à plat leur présence médiatique
est très important aussi bien à titre
d'exemple pour les enfants que pour les
adultes aussi parce que c'est une très
belle image de madame ski de haut niveau
présent il passe toute une journée avec
nos partenaires
mais il ya également aussi je pense une
grande confiance en ce que ces sportifs
à une fois les enfants ils se déplacent
ainsi à l'étranger dans le monde et il
boit
merci à tous les besoins qu'on a pour
scolariser les enfants l'écho pour boire
beaucoup de choses que ce soit fait dans
ce sens
au niveau sportif aussi skis et monier
s'est qui s'activait avec les maillots
et que et bankable comme andy jeter des
enchères caritative et que du coup leur
pré vente donne une valeur énorme et
cette année en plus d'avoir un objet
mythique aux enchères c'est à dire que
les coûts de voleurs ont proposé une
soirée foot avec un joueur de tennis
après une heure de tennis aux enchères
ils vont mettre en scène leur propre
personne les athées génial ces nouveaux
génome en we walk on l'avait fait il ya
trois quatre ans de manière un petit peu
cette année est une année yannick noah
avait monté les enchères offert une
heure de tennis garden il avait explosé
les compteurs et du coup cette année
ainsi que comme depuis un an on était là
mais nos besoins tenue jaune vraiment
besoin de nous une manière de récolter
des fonds dans un bon esprit
quel est le plus beau lot si je peux me
permettre cette année alors qu'il ya des
cas c'est à dévoyer ce ce superbe
gilbert privé et par contact
il y aura des meilleurs connaisseurs de
foot sont en train de tricoter des
maillots de rugby et la raquette de
tennis de roland garros en général ccc
prise s'offre à quai à quel prix
justement
alors pour toutes les bourses
100% des thons sont ensuite reversés aux
enfants et ça va coller à l'école auront
jusqu'à 3000 4000 euros pour le
mon bonheur de nos gens alors toutes les
mesures vous l'avez dit un seront
appliquées 1 c'est ça au golf de hersant
ses cinq départs vague de départs on va
aménager les choses pour que ça reste
très convivial
mais que ne seraient pas des distances
et que tout le monde se sente en toute
sécurité
c'est bien qu'on va faire du mal aux
couleurs de sa gazelle on va faire des
petites bosses dames est ronde aux
couleurs de l'association pour rappeler
les distances et tous les festivités
vont perdre en extérieur puisqu'on a
appris la bonne nouvelle ce matin
quelques sourires l'intérieur dans sas
et c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
on a décidé que tout se passe à
l'extérieur du matin du score jusqu'au
soir et évidemment les olympiades pour
les enfants à l'extérieur alors ce sera
donc au golf de hersant pourquoi
pourquoi ce golf alors ce sera en dehors
des yvelines
je crois que c'est une première c'est
une première ça fait 28 ans qu'on est
dans les yvelines mais on est à vingt
minutes de mantes la jolie
alors le code parc robert hersant quand
je suis à l'ondé et deux choix
c'est un lieu magique que tous les
golfeurs et tous les types de haut
niveau adorf et était un rêve de jouer
sur ce parcours il émaille il est très
beau pour les non hold up bois
il ya des espaces d'accueil superbe et
surtout j'ai trouvé un esprit de
solidarité dans tout du golf où se
retrouveront à cadres se boire dans
l'opération totalement caritatives et
j'ai trouvé notre chaleur humaine et
c'est ça dont on a besoin pour se sentir
bien pour que les champions sont
complètement à l'aise l'écueil
partenaires otis ouaga donc c'est un
endroit qui est tout près des villes
donc on regarde où on garde notamment
des idées mais avec une alors l'ensemble
des bénéfices sera reversée à
l'association sos gazelles est ce que
vous pouvez vous rappeler un petit peu
les actions des sceaux s gazelle
est-ce que c'est l'éducation par le
sport et la santé
donc nous préconisons dans plusieurs
pays dans le monde et également en
france des événements support pour
encadrer les jeunes
nous leur offrons aussi des moyens de
pourvoir à tous qui est santé et
prévention santé
nous faisons des scolarisation d'enfants
n'ont pas les moyens
nous les mettons dans des écoles privées
et encadrée et nous construisons
également les aménagements pour des
clubs où il se rend compte dans l'est
dans les pays les plus pauvres et
potagers et des vergers pour qu'ils
puissent être correctement nourris
donc il ya tout un encadrement et en
fait nous prenons au projet par projet
quand on donne moi et nous étudions la
légitimité mais également aussi la
qualité de la personne qui tient le
projet en face de nous pour qu'on soit
sûr qu'il y ait une pérennité d'un la
question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour cette édition 2021 alors
le premier oui on souhaitait comme on
peut souhaiter à chaque français et
chaque humain c'est que ce qu vide au
mois de mai on puisse presque un filet
dernière lorsque le fleuve on ne fera
pas terminé mais chacun aura ans
habitait fait ce qu'il fallait pour que
ça se stabilise et qu'enfin on revivre
les gens sont à bout et justement ce
genre d'événement conviviaux où les gens
se retrouvent dessin clairement la
chaleur humaine tous les jours je vois
des gens même jane pitt sont moralement
très atteint donc ce que vous pouvez
nous souhaiter c'est que cet événement
se passait dans son intégralité
beaucoup de bonne humeur et beaucoup de
joie de se retrouver parce que la
relation humaine n'a pas de prix
et c'est ça qui est l'essence même de la
vie merci à vous véronique chaplin le
tiebreak c'est le 19 mai au golf de
hersant on va terminer par du cyclisme
et une image c'était vendredi dernier à
chatou le maire de la commune eric
moulin et le président du département
pierre bédier ont inauguré un compte à
rebours géant pour annoncer la venue du
tour de france dans la commune il a été
installé sur le rond-point maupassant
renoir du quartier europe la ville
accueillera l'événement le 18 juillet
prochain après rambouillet et
mantes-la-jolie les meilleurs cyclistes
du monde passeront donc par les yvelines
pour la troisième année consécutive à
l'occasion de la dernière étape
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]